White House Counsel done began
reportedly does not believe his
testimony to Special Counsel Robert
Muller implicated President Trump in any
legal wrongdoing the president said in
an interview yesterday that he's worried
about falling into a quote perjury trap
if he talks to Muller major Garrett is
at the White House major a good morning
good morning also in that interview with
Reuters the president said that the
ongoing Special Counsel investigation
quote played right into the Russians
hands also here in Washington
Republicans again expressed their
concern about the president's
unrelenting attacks on Special Counsel
Robert Muller have you briefed the White
House on everything you told the special
counsel White House Counsel dawn McGann
dodged questions Monday about his role
as a witness in the Russia investigation
President Trump called the probe a quote
national disgrace mr. Trump made this
claim about the special counsels
investigation I can go in and I could do
whatever I could run it if I wanted the
president told Reuters but I decided to
stay out the president's suggestion he
could run an inquiry into his own
conduct raised more questions about his
understanding of obstruction of justice
an area of interest to Muller mr. Trump
also said he was reluctant to give an
interview to Muller because it could be
a potential perjury trap expressing
fears that investigators could compare
his version of the firing of James Comey
against the notes and recollections of
the former FBI director it's my word
against his and he's best friends with
Muller so Muller might say well I
believe Comey and even if I'm telling
the truth that makes me a liar that's no
good as he has before Arizona Republican
Jeff Flake said mr. Trump was out of
line this is unseemly frankly to go
after
you know career officers over at justice
to go after Bob ball or the way he's
going after him
the president also told Reuters he might
lift sanctions on Russia if there's
cooperation from Moscow on Syria and
Ukraine both seem highly unlikely
cooperation and Congress going along
with any lifting a Russia sanctions
viana major thanks